hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the dimensions of the virtue of
temperance to which Cicero devotes quite
a bit of attention in on duties book one
which is his treatise on stoic ethics is
action or behavior the sort of things
that we do how we manifest ourselves
externally here I'm not going to talk
about language or conversation since
that's something that he also devotes
attention to and I'm not going to go
back over all the discussions of the
four characters because there's a
separate discussion of that that you can
you can easily look up here I want to
focus specifically in on action and
behavior and what else he has to say
about that in this section so the first
thing to start from is is kind of in the
middle this is from chapter 39 should be
and he says that we have three key ideas
three key things that we have to keep in
mind if we want to be moderate if we
want to be temperate if we want to be
self-control and first among these and
actually the most important according to
Cicero is that what he calls impulse or
appetite if we want to translate a
little bit more literally the desires
the affective side of ourselves is
obedient to it listens to is another way
of translating it reason he says that we
have these these parts to ourselves you
know the lower parts is a very familiar
to anybody who study Plato Aristotle or
the Stoics and then we have this higher
part our rationality and we should be
following that often difficult to do and
any actions we sometimes start out being
reasonable or being governed by reason
and then as they go on we we lose sight
of that the second thing that he says
that I think is really interesting has
to do not just with reason being in
charge but that we have to devote the as
he says the right amount of care
and attention Curra that's Oprah in in
Latin Cora is care or attention and then
Oprah could be understood as is
attention or if you mean we might think
the energy that we put into it the
amount of work that's another good
translation the work that we put into it
so we don't want to be expending too
much so you know for example I have
students when I assign them a one to one
point five page paper who turned in a
five page paper and I you know
oftentimes they're quite good and I'll
tell them well this is a great paper but
I don't want you to be writing that much
I want you to be concentrating on other
things that's why I assigned you such a
short paper to work on and we can say
similar things with so much other
examples you know when somebody is a
perfectionist right they're they're
devoting a lot of care and attention to
things but it might be actually too much
and in a certain way it's obeying reason
but it's obeying reason in the wrong way
so he says we have to estimate carefully
the importance of the object that we
wish to accomplish we have to think
about whether it's a high priority or
whether it's lower down in the scale of
importance and if it's lower down then
we don't devote quite as much care and
attention to it
although attention to detail is
important right and if it's higher up
then then perhaps it requires more in
relation to other things the xxx says
the third principle is that we have to
be careful to observe moderation in all
that is essential to the outward
appearance and dignity of a gentleman
that's a little old-fashioned a little
old-timey way to phrase it but I think
that we can make it more contemporary by
saying that we should maintain
moderation by behaving like a decent
human being
behaving like somebody who has a sense
of honor a sense of what's appropriate a
proper sense not not an inflated
egotistical sense and not a deflated
sort of pathological humility sort of
sense but a proper sense of what is is
appropriate within the circumstances and
this me this means remaining within
certain limits now if we follow all
three of these together then our actions
are going to be you could say well
regulated and therefore will be not just
temperate but will also as we go through
time help to make us more temperate it
gives us some other interesting criteria
here that I think are worth talking
about earlier on in the discussion he
tells us that and this is a very typical
stoic position that our physical comfort
and and our wants and we have many of
them should be regulated
not according to pleasure or our desire
for pleasure or avoidance of pain but
should be regulated or ordered in
relation to health and strength of the
body so the body has certain needs let's
take for example eating right how much
should we eat and what kind of food
should we eat now we live here in the
first world in a as you know people like
to joke target-rich environment right
you can walk down almost any street and
go into a store and find all sorts of
food that you can purchase fairly
cheaply that's probably not good for you
it's going to taste sweet or salty if
that's what you're looking for or meaty
you know go and buy some beef jerky or
something like that and you can often
get lots and lots of it so you can get
food that's very tasty in a certain
sense and you can get plenty of it now
is that is that what you should be
eating well if you regulate things
according to pleasure you're just going
to stuff your face with all sorts of
food that's not particularly healthy if
you orient yourself by what's actually
good for your body you can eat food
that's satisfying I mean if you're
trying to lose weight and you're going
cold turkey off of a fast food or candy
rich or something
like that diet it's gonna feel rather
painful to you but you know you you
certainly can arrive at a point where
you're just you've got some temperance
when you go to the buffet if it's
all-you-can-eat you don't that doesn't
mean you have to eat everything you can
cram it into your gut right that means
that you can have some of this and have
some of this but it requires no notice
if you're going to do something like
that you do have to make your impulses
obey reason you also have to set your
priorities correctly right and then you
have to maintain moderation in order to
do that another important point that he
he talks about is very similar to
Aristotle's notion of the virtuous mean
and he tells us in chapter 25 or 35 that
our actions in in the in the style that
we're displaying them they should be
neither too soft and another word that
it uses there is effeminate you know
it's not going to work all that well
unless we sort of you know generalize
this because you know plenty of women
are also going to apply Cicero's dicta
as well but not too rough as well so you
want the actions that you're doing and
the way that you're doing them to be
done in the middle position he talks
about people who trail their cloak
behind them and walk around like you
know it's it's a burden to move their
body okay well that would be too soft
then we can think about you know other
people who walk around and they're tough
all the time and you know they're gonna
bump you out of their way and when they
open a door they open it really hard to
show you how how you know strong they
are accessor would say those people are
idiots you know that's that's not
remotely like temperance as a matter of
fact it's probably not even showing real
bravery people like that are usually
quite insecure so that that's an
important consideration as well he also
says there are some other considerations
and he discusses in chapter 40 conduct
he says should be
orderly and here he uses the word order
you know or dome and seasonable now what
does he mean by seasonable he means at
the right time he's using the the Greek
terms and Latin terms for this so the
orderliness you toxeus arranged in the
right way and then with the timely or
seasonable he says this is a yeah who
Correa Kairos means time in Greek and it
means well or or proper or right and so
doing things at the right time so think
about you know for example when you
ought to give somebody bad news should
you burst in right away and give them
bad news as soon as possible maybe not
you have to think about what is the
right occasion to do this and how should
you approach them should you be you know
crying your eyes out even though it's
not really your bad news it's more of
their bad news probably not now there's
one other consideration that he brings
up as well that's very interesting and I
don't think that we see people talking
about this all that often he says that
our behavior ought to be consistent and
here you might think that Cicero in his
moderation is perhaps being a little bit
intemperate going a bit too far with
what he's demanding of people he says
but here's a nice metaphor orderliness
of conduct is to be observed so that
everything in the conduct of our life
should balance and harmonize as in a
finished speech so he's using a metaphor
here of some sort of composition
everything within the way that we act
should be connected with and consist
with everything else we shouldn't be a
bundle of contradictions we shouldn't be
compartmentalized so that we behave one
way with these people over here and a
very different way with people over here
in ways that that people who see us
acting in both you know contexts say
what's going on there this seems to be a
different person
we should have consistency across the
board and so you know he he says a
little bit later on as therefore a
musical ear detects even the slightest
falsity of tone in the harp so we if we
wish to be keen and observers of moral
faults shall often draw important
conclusions from trifles we observe
others and from a glance of the eyes
from a contracting and relaxing the
brows from an air of sadness from an
outburst of joy from a laugh from speech
from silence from raising or lowering
the voice we shall easily judge which of
our actions are proper and which is out
of accord with duty and nature so the
idea is that entire range of stuff that
we've talked about they should all
harmonize with each other now that's a
very difficult ideal to reach I'm sure
you know I certainly haven't done it
myself but this is what Cicero does
think about what temperance in action
and behavior would look like for us
you